[Applause]
welcome back y'all we are celebrating
Christmas with taji Hinton give it
up you can see her in the color purple
starting Christmas day in theaters
speaking of Christmas day uh Taraji and
I both love it so some might say a
little too much but who cares we don't
care what you think we love Christmas
and you will not take it so we thought
taji would be the perfect person to play
our annual Christmas game here's this
year's round of the christm hostess the
Christmas
host
host it's really hard to say if I'm
being honest I here to host is a good
friend of the show you can see him on
that clip show holiday edition tonight
on NBC everybody give it up for our
friend Matt
[Applause]
[Music]
Usman oh good to see you
again is this your first time being on
our New York yes well thank you I love
being here I what better Christmas
spirit gift than to be here with Kelly
and Taj I I
AG so tell us about the game we are
ready all right so this is how
christmess Hostess works I'm GNA ask you
a series of questions about Christmas
Christmas parties and Christmas decor if
you get the question right you get a
point but if you get it wrong you have
to take a shot of that delicious but
filling eggnog in front of you okay now
steals are allowed yes but if you get it
wrong on a steel you still do a shot
okay the winner will get a gift for her
side of the
audience they always love that part and
we'll have her name inscribed on the
christmess hostess ornament that will
live on at the Kelly Clarkson show for
many all right ladies all right the
stakes have never been higher buzz in
when you think you know the answer are
you ready for Chris Mo's
Hostess here we go first question okay
what Kissy Kissy Christmas decoration
mistletoe my
God we going to win baby we going to
win that was very fast Kissy Kissy I
need more caffine I'm not a betting man
I didn't know if he was going song or
mistletoe I didn't know I just took a
chance went for it I'm going to lose
visions of losing danc in her head y yep
question two what decorative shell
splitter is also the name elf where's my
elf hiding elf that is in
correct teraji take a
[Applause]
shot you don't have to take the whole
thing
W okay okay okay I'mma get some more
wrong all right
Kelly you have a chance to steal down
one point what decorative shell splitter
is also the name of a Christmas
ballet no no I get it I get it poer I
get it taji you already got this one
wrong oh this is for Kelly Kelly do you
know the answer
Nutcracker
oh my go question three what are two
other names for Santa Claus oh Kelly St
Nick yes and um uh Chris Kringle
yes I
will for those keeping score at home
taji did not get the question wrong but
she still did a shot oh it's two to one
and taji has three shots of eggnog play
eggnog question number four my stomach
would I believe I heard the Jingle Bells
which means we finished there is one
question left and and and this one wins
everything well teraji this could be
worth six
points six points at stake the title of
christmus Hostess on the line last
question okay on the third day of
Christmas what did my true love tell I
you won't
even three three golden hens no
incorrect
Kaji you must get this correct to to win
the chrisos
ddal oh it's
no we need an answer at this moment what
is it
fren three
fren you are the champ I knew bir tell I
knew it was a
bird cuz I are you going to take one
I'll take one I'll take one with you sal
sal
you know how I know it's real I mean
because it tastes amazing that is so
good so good I hope it don't hit me
later okay it is so good though um of
course we are all winners around here
iconic Australian Footwear brand Frankie
for is changing the lives of everyday
women especially those that are on their
feet all day long their gamechanging
sneakers Flats heels and boots have
podiatrist design support which has
earned them over 100,000 fivestar
reviews and a global following and
you're all going home with a $300
Frankie for gift
card thank you for hosting Welcome to
our New
York everybody be sure to watch tonight
that show holiday edition on NC and to R
his movie is The Color Purple go in
theat starting Christmas day we'll be
right back with gry winning artist
Killer
[Applause]
[Music]
Mike
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home